there's a lot on the line when it comes
to human social lives so much in fact
that a person's place on the social
ladder might determine how long that
person lives social adversities effect
on human health has surfaced in many
studies which show how income social
integration and adverse childhood
experiences are linked to lifespan and
even the prevalence of specific diseases
during life a recent scientific review
outlined these social risk factors known
as the social determinants of health
across years of research into humans
using data collected from the literature
they plotted how men earning $35,000 or
less at age 40 are expected to live
fewer years than those earning $100,000
or more a social integration composite
based on marital status frequency of
social contacts and community engagement
showed least socially integrated women
were more than twice as likely to suffer
from stroke than the most integrated and
people who had six or more adverse
childhood experiences were expected to
die nearly twenty years earlier than
those who experienced none but what
possibly set this review apart from
others was that the authors compared
human studies with those in several
other groups of mammals rodents horses
whales and even higher axes have been
shown to exhibit important health
outcomes that correlate with their
social environment and relationships of
course other primates display similar
patterns one study found that male
Assamese macaques who form stronger
social bonds with other males ascended
the hierarchy and also fathered more
young and the literature review
identifies a pathway and baboons in
which social adversity early life
adversity and mediators of those events
for the delicate interplay to affect
health fitness and lifespan
but the scientists who tend to study
these furry creatures often stand apart
from the scientists who studies social
health factors in humans the two
scientific fields seemingly dig for the
same results but do so in parallel
tunnels which usually stand apart as a
consequence these fields of study might
be missing out on resources that could
be game changers and understanding the
social determinants of health including
its biological mechanisms and humans and
behavioral or environmental mediators in
other animals the review hurled a monkey
wrench into the structure thrusting
human social science into the fray with
the study of animal behavior rather than
viewing them as strict parallels the
review suggested combining them hoping
to reap the benefits of these isolated
fields working in tandem future
large-scale genomic studies can
integrate research on social health
factors to give a more complete picture
of negative health effects in humans
research on hierarchies could address
whether climbing a social ladder
benefits lifespan or whether a more
egalitarian community improves an
individual's longevity ultimately the
review stresses that humans have a long
history of dependence on the social
environment which in evolutionary terms
may be older than our species itself
insight into social stressors across the
animal kingdom could help us tackle the
greatest challenges in public health for
years to come
you